une décision importante en matière de
santé publique et qui intéressera tous
ceux qui ont eu recours à des coupes
faim pour tenter de maigrir
la cour de cassation a confirmé la
condamnation d'un laboratoire qui
fabriquait l'un de ses médicaments
l'isoméride une femme avait porté
plainte parce que le traitement avait
provoqué une hypertension artérielle
pulmonaire
elle avait dû subir une greffe des deux
poumons à une opération du coeur laurent
d'ibr numério à l'avenir cet avocat
n'aura plus à ouvrir l'imposant dossier
qui occupe une partie de son bureau sa
cliente a gagné mais après une longue
bataille luttant procédure procédure
devant un tribunal procédure devant la
cour d'appel de versailles procédure
devant la cour de cassation
nous avions rencontré un appel aux sens
1998 au début de son marathon judiciaire
quatre ans avant cela elle avait dû
subir une greffe des deux poumons plus
une opération du coeur à cause soutenait
tel d'un médicament l'isoméride un coupe
faim car médecins lui avaient prescrit
le médicament a été retiré par son
fabricant en 97
mais la justice vient seulement de
reconnaître le lien de causalité entre
la maladie et le médicament les experts
médicaux arrive à la notion que la
causalité est adéquate c'est à dire que
la maladie ne peut pas avoir d'autres
causes que l'abstention du médicament
jusqu'à présent il fallait démontrer de
façon certaine la causalité entre la
maladie et le produit chimique
désormais les choses s'assouplissent
c'est une grande avancée puisque
maintenant pour la première fois le
doute profite à la victime
au lieu de profiter de profiter à
l'accusé donc le doute va permettre
d'indemniser
nos victimes le laboratoire servier est
condamnée à quatre cent mille euros de
dommages et intérêts et ce n'est pas
fini
une dizaine de procédures sont en cours
contre le groupe pharmaceutique
mais cet arrêt de la cour suprême
française pourrait aussi marquer la
jurisprudence dans d'autres dossiers de
responsabilité médicale comme les anti
cholestérol par exemple là